دا بهذا الخبر الذي اوردناه في بدايه
النشره نقلا عن الجيش الاسرائيلي بان عدد
الاصابات في صفوف الجيش بلغت
429 بين ضابط وجندي وذلك منذ بدء الحرب هل
من تفاصيل و هل من ردود
فعل ليلى واضح بان هذه الاحصائيات التي
يريدها الجيش الاسرائيلي تعكس حقيقه حجم
المعارك الضاريه التي شهدها قطاع غزه في
الشهور الاخيره وهو يتحدث عن
429 ضابطا وجنديا اصيبوا بجروح خطيره من
بين الاف الجرحى ال الجرحى في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث رسميا
اليوم عن اكثر من 2800 جندي وضابط اصيبوا
في المعارك منذ بدايه هذه الحرب في السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي واكثر من 1300 منذ بدايه
الهجوم البري وه هنالك حوالي 350 ضابطا
وجنديا ما زالوا يرقدون للعلاج في
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه على الاقل 25 منهم
وصفت جراحهم بانها خطيره للغايه وهذه
الارقام حقيقه ليلى ايه تعكس حجم المعارك
الضاريه التي شهدها قطاع غزه في الاسابيع
والشهور الماضيه لكن علينا ان نلفت
الانتباه ايضا الى احصاء جديد كان اورده
الجيش الاسرائيلي يوم امس واشار الى ان
540 ضابطا وجنديا اصيبوا جراء حوادث
عمليات وجراء نيران صديقه في خضم هذه
المعارك الضاريه في قطاع غزه وهذا ليلى
عدد كبير للغايه على اعتبار ان هذا يعكس
كما يبدو حاله الارباك الموجوده في صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي وانعدام التنسيق بين
الالويه المختلفه التي عملت في عموم قطاع
غزه تحديدا منذ بدايه الهجوم البري نحن
نتحدث عن عده الويه عملت في المناطق
الشماليه والوسطى وعلى الاقل سبعه الويه
عملت في منطقه خانيونس الان اصبحت خمسه
الويه لكن هذا العدد الكبير من الجرحى
جراء
ال الحوادث السير احيانا وسوء استخدام
الاسلحه والمتفجرات في احيان اخرى ونحو 54
جنديا وضابطا اصيبوا على الاقل بنيران
صديق كما تورد احصائيات الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذا يعكس حاله من الارباك في ارض المعركه
في ميادين المعارك المختلفه على كل
المحاور ويعكس ايضا سوءا في اداره المعارك
وحاله من الارباك الشديده بين الالويه
المختلفه وحقيقه عدم تنسيق واضح رغم ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان يتحدث عن نسبه عاليه
من التنسيق ما بين قواته البريه والجويه
وسلاح البحريه لكن من الواضح بان مستوى
والتنسيق على مستوى الوحدات البريه التي
اشتغلت في المحاور المختلفه كان كما يبدو
سيئا وهذه النتائج او هذه الارقام تعكس
ذلك حقيقه ل